do you think the Dragons Were Made using
practical effects or green screen and
how much muscle do you think Michelle
Rodriguez gained to play a barbarian in
Dungeons and Dragons honor among Thieves
which DND monster are you most excited
to see on the big screen like there are
a number of monsters in the film that
actually come from the original board
game like say owl Bears which is a
monstrosity that Doric can turn into a
druid when asked how they were able to
handle her Transformations Sophia lilis
revealed that that was one of the few
effects done with the use of CGI but
clarifying they did as much with
practical effects as they possibly could
Our Heroes also face off against
displacer beasts and mimics and even a
gelatinous cube that may be in the movie
for a reason whenever Jonathan Goldstein
would play the game with his older
brother as a kid I'd fall into a
gelatinous cube every time and trust us
he has not forgotten it I had to get my
revenge on my older brother look at me
now Dan just like you shouldn't forget
to hit that subscribe button for more
movie trivia going back to the movie's
practical effects for a minute here did
you realize that the Dragons Were Made
using puppets okay well they weren't
made using only puppets reggae John Page
revealed that the Dragons Were a mix
between kind of Jim hensonesque puppetry
and green screen reggae Jean found it
very interesting to be acting opposite
this huge creature that's half in your
imagination and half in the real world
he found that the puppets would often
give such scary good performances that
it would sort of inspire him as an actor
often leaving him thinking nah you're
not gonna act me out of this that's not
happening wow Hugh Grant on the other
hand joked that he found the dragons to
be annoying because during moments where
he thought I'm rather good in this shot
he'd look closer and see one of the
bloody Dragon things walks through the
background of the shot so I'm hoping
they're gonna be the creatures are
largely going to be cut out of this at
all right but the costumes for this
movie were no laughing matter they had
to be made perfectly because many of
these characters would be wearing the
same thing throughout the entire filming
process and like most of the cast didn't
really have a problem with that but
Sophia lillis had to deal with some
major wardrobe malfunctions she had to
wear two corsets at all times and any
time that she needed to get out of it to
go to the bathroom it took like a good
40 minutes the only part of her costume
that was done using CGI was her tail
otherwise it was all real Sophia had to
wear a wig with a metal bit underneath
and her magnetic horn stuck out through
holes in the wig and her ears were
Prosthetics and they would sort of get
in her way whenever it came time for her
to perform her stunt work oh and
speaking of stunt work Sophia lillis had
to do a lot to play Doric she mostly had
to focus on learning how to roll both
forward and backward I'm not really a
acrobatic person but the character was
and Sophia wasn't alone Michelle
Rodriguez had a trainer come in to work
with her every day helping her to gain
10 pounds worth of muscle for her role
as a barbarian it was great actually
hadn't done that since I was in my 20s
and what about Chris Pine you may be
wondering really she was training I
wasn't Chris actually enjoyed making
himself look as bad as possible to the
point that the directors had to remind
him to look heroic in some scenes he
seems intent on being the lamest hero in
the Forgotten Realms do you know where
this movie is supposed to take place as
we mentioned before it's set in the
fictional Forgotten Realms and it
explores a few familiar locations like
the city of Neverwinter and the Frozen
wastelands of icewind Dale although the
movie does plan on taking us to places
never seen in the games before but in
order to bring these Fantastical places
to life the crew needed to take filming
someplace equally as magical and where
better to go than the magical lands of
Northern Ireland the movie was shot out
of a number of gorgeous historical sites
throughout the UK like the carrickfergus
castle and this definitely helped to
capture that tolkien-like universe that
Roy Lee mentioned earlier but if they
ever did need to build an original set
Sophia lillis made it clear that
production wasn't afraid to do that the
movie isn't only inspired by the games
it's growing the game's lore the film's
writers have been working closely with
the game's Publishers Wizards of the
Coast and they noticed right away there
were things that posed challenges one
problem was that the script opened up
with a prison right at the beginning but
until that point there had never been a
prison in the DND world and so Wizards
of the Coast helped to build the
writer's ideas into the existing lore
helping them to decide things like who
would run such a prison DND artist
Jeremy Jarvis wanted to make sure the
writers understood that this
civilization has been there for a while
so there's layers to it and the writers
definitely tried to make that clear in
the movie but considering how long
they've had to work on it we wouldn't
expect anything less these characters
are not your average Heroes co-director
Jonathan Goldstein wanted to tell a
story set in a fantasy environment using
characters who were not superheroes
instead he wanted all of them to be
incredibly flawed this would do a better
job of making the movie feel like the
board game because when you play D D you
roll your character's characteristics
and you don't always get a 20 as he put
it some of these guys have clearly
rolled like a four but that doesn't mean
they stay that way over the course of
the movie they level up Jonathan may be
trying to distance the movie from
superheroes but his description
definitely makes sense with the way that
producer Roy Lee put it a Guardians of
the Galaxy tone movie in a tolkien-like
universe now we wonder how many of our
stars were familiar with the universe
before being cast in it which member of
the cast do you think was the biggest
DND fan well if you guessed Chris Pine
you'd actually be wrong sorry he never
even played the board game before being
cast in the movie but luckily he
actually had a really great teacher my
nephew plays it uh religiously and has
for years when he found out that his
super cool uncle had a role in the movie
they got together with a couple of
family members to play the game Chris
described the group as being essentially
All actors and former actors and he said
that this really helped him enjoy the
game more because it is just like improv
class otherwise Michelle Rodriguez has
been playing the game for years in fact
her Fast and the Furious co-star Vin
Diesel is a mega fan but Sophia lillis
is definitely the best player in the
group her co-stars have called her the
LeBron of DnD and playing through High
School definitely helped her become more
familiar with the monsters in the movie
oh that funny you it's a good thing he
has a sense of humor because that's a
big part of the reason why he's here to
most of the cast in Dungeons and Dragons
honor among Thieves makes sense Chris
Pine has served as the leading man to
the franchise like Star Trek and Wonder
Woman before and Sophia lillis has been
a huge fan of DnD since high school
which may explain why she was willing to
put up with so much for the role but
what about someone like Hugh Grant who's
not only unfamiliar with the game well
he's also avoided appearing in big
franchises for years now even he'd tell
you that when he first heard he was
being considered for a role in the new
Dungeons and Dragons movie The only
thing he thought was I don't think so
but when he actually sat down to read
the script he found that the big appeal
of the movie was the fact that it
genuinely made him laugh Dungeons and
Dragons was almost an entirely different
movie this is one of those projects
that's been stuck in development for
years having been teased all the way
back in 2013. since then it's traded
hands from Studio to studio and it's had
a number of intriguing names attached to
it in 2016 a version of the movie was
planned that would be directed by Rob
Letterman and starring Ansel Elgort Joe
Manganiello was working on the script
while Dwayne Johnson and Brad Payton
were in talks to develop it now all this
was before Hasbro decided to move the
rights over to Paramount Pictures in
2017 forcing them to start again with a
new cast and crew but it's hard to say
how much the writers may have taken from
Joe manganiello's finished script
the movie we got may not have been the
movie that was planned but you can see
the passion that this cast has for the
source material which part of the game
are you most excited to see on screen or
what do you think was handled the best
we love to hear your thoughts so don't
forget to make them heard down below